we're told a sociologist studying
fertility in Argentina and Bolivia
wanted to test if there was a difference
in the average number of babies women in
each country have the sociologist
obtained a random sample of women from
each country here are the results of
their tests so they take a sample of 75
women in Argentina and these women had a
mean of 2.4 babies each with a standard
deviation of 1.5 and then the standard
error of the mean was zero point one
seven and then they calculated similar
statistics for a bolivia and then they
give us the t-test
for the means being different and we
were able to calculate these statistics
and they say assume that all conditions
for inference have been met at the alpha
equals 0.05 level of significance is
there sufficient evidence to conclude
that there is a difference in the
average number of babies women in each
country have so pause this video and see
if you can answer that all right
now let's work through this together so
this is classic hypothesis testing right
over here where your null hypothesis is
actually going to be that your means are
the same so that the mean and Argentina
is equal to the mean in Bolivia and then
your alternative hypothesis is that your
means are different and what you do is
you say all right if we assume the null
hypothesis what is the probability that
we would have gotten means this far
apart and that's what our p-value tells
us that we have a 0.3 one probability or
a 31% probability of getting means this
far apart now if your probability
assuming the null hypothesis is below
your level of significance your alpha
right over here then you would say all
right that seems like such a low
probability I'll reject the null
hypothesis which suggests the
alternative hypothesis but in
this situation here if we compare our P
to our alpha we see that our p value is
for sure greater than our alpha so in
this situation I mean you could see it
right over here zero point three one is
for sure greater than 0.05 so in this
situation we cannot reject the null
hypothesis cannot reject our null
hypothesis and so there is not
sufficient evidence to conclude that
there is a difference in the average
number of babies women in each country
have